Back to our regularly scheduled program.
Let's see where you are.
You want an upper bound on time.
You took the DAG and
you broke it up into a bunch of phases.
And each phase k does w k units of work.
And the time to execute each phase
is the ceiling of w k over p,
and it's these pesky ceilings
that we want to get rid of.
Let me help you.
I don't want you to be
angry like this little guy.
Grr.
Here's a fact.
I can take a ceiling of a quotient and
turn it into a floor.
Plug that in and see what you get.
Now I know what you're thinking.
Curse you that gets rid of the ceiling
but the floor seems just as bad.
Remember our original question
was to get an upper bound.
So can we get an upper
bound on the summand?
Now the floor of something is always
less than or equal to that something.
Aha.
That gives an upper bound and
eliminates the floor.
Oh no, I'm falling into a pit!
Okay, this looks a lot cleaner.
Now you just need a little algebra and
the fact that summing all
these Wks will give you W.
And putting that all together,
you get your first interesting result.
Congratulations.
This is Brent's theorem.
And what you've done is very
interpretative to interpret to
Brent's Theorem says that the time
to execute the DAG is no more than
the time to execute the critical path,
plus the time to execute off of the
critical path using the P processors.
This result also sets a goal for
any scheduler.
So let's say someone is trying to sell
you his or her scheduling algorithm,
you can look at him or her and you can
say, now wait just a unit of time there.
Can you scheduler execute any
DAG within Brent's time bound?
You will look so smart and
sophisticated, if you do that.
Let me close by emphasizing
one final point.
What you just derived is an upper bound.
That is, given a DAG,
Brent predicts the upper limit on time.
But you also had these lower bounds.
Now an interesting factoid
is that this upper limit and
this lower limit are both within
a factor of two of one another.
Can you see why?
In any case, what this means is that you
may be able to execute the DAG in a time
that is less than what Brent predicts.
Though of course you can never go
any faster than the lower bound,
at least in theory.
Let's see how this works.